[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh hello there oh I did that that that
fast hot switch how's it going everyone
we're back and we've switched chairs and
more importantly we are back with
Bayonetta 1 & 2 on the switch yeah we
are do you want say anything before we
just switch over to the feed I love and
I'm okay at it don't make fun of me
perfect we're in for a good time let's
do it
I did it I'm a professional is there
game audio you know that's what I'm
wondering maybe not at this part cuz
it's the there it is there it is
okay it's just the title screens very
quiet wait there yeah so if you need any
more volume adjustments oh hey look at
that awesome splatoon controller
Bayonetta Bayonetta on switch we're
gonna chair up ain't had a one for a
just kind of intro this one but then
we're gonna go in a two because I think
that's the two is the one we're here for
people are really excited about without
a doubt I'm excited that a lot of people
are gonna get a chance to play - I
didn't get a play it before yeah they
put it out on the Wii U which I'm
thankful that Nintendo swooped in to
save the day but like they're like five
people who bought a wii u and those five
people all played the game
somebody says yo GameSpot what's up
someone says hey what's up
somebody says hurry up that's rude and
we're working I'm sorry please we should
stream Bayonetta 3 I have hell yeah we
shared them sign me up as soon as as
soon as you hear about that one I'm in
so we're gonna watch this really cool
interest yeah we should probably just
not talk to her the volume is good
ah the man himself locked me on Twitter
say that Hideki Kamiya had one of his
characters piss on his grave yeah you
know he's really into his art antonius
is the voice on the introvert is
Bayonetta is different no actually it's
not different every time you if you
start it up and then you go because of
different things differently so it does
it still do the way you remember doing
it
what you didn't know is that multiple
people do it somebody wants to know if
it's true that banana for the switches
scored a 10 out of 10 it did because the
Wii U version we gave a 10 and the
switch version is still just as good and
now you can take it everywhere you go
continues to be a 10 this is such a good
intro to this character to all these
characters which one Bayonetta be
another mushy and not Joe Pesci like
everything about this game's story and
presentation
reminds me of a ps2 game yeah yeah the
best way having issues with Bayonetta 2
in doc mode with the voice sounds barely
being able to be heard huh maybe it's a
volume setting cuz me if it's like
surround and it's coming out of I had a
bunch of issues with my switch and my
speaker system oh like dogs like where
it wouldn't work and the way I got
around it was actually plugged my switch
into a splitter then I could before I
would not even get any audio which was
really annoying
fix the game sound bring it up more look
ever get out more
I'm down I got you
[Music]
what is this they really just we're like
can you do a good job patchy like hold
my beer
I've got you there's nobody audio at all
what are we is a muted
try that oh did I I grab the wrong
things probably but that's weird because
you can hear it
yeah alright we've raised it up a little
what happen is you have the wrong
channel up so it was only one channel
that would do it there we go see we
figured it out guys I'm sorry I've done
this twice I just remembered what
happens after this and I'm faceted same
just waiting for the music to kick in
that's that's when you know what's going
down
[Music]
Oh affinity to my favorite statin
monster on her it might be a little bit
too loud now yes like I brought it down
a little bit
do the line not that one now that's not
that's not what I want
on his birthday I think I know the line
you're talking about yeah
[Music]
[Laughter]
ah this dude is cool it's wrote does it
wrote in a road on de road on but I
think it's Road I think Joe Pesci says
road on ah it can't just be a normal
scene
start throwing those guns dude these
jams he lights it with his finger so was
asking if we've try it with the joy
Kahn's yet not yet but we'll try it oh
this is the line I think your yep and
then to do the flip in suplex seven
angels at once yes sure was that the
line you were thinking of that's not the
one else really I was waiting for the
opposite line I was I was waiting for
the the let's dance boys but I remember
that's probably not gonna happen
the very end of the game I just like
that line a lot ah yes
surprise under my outfit I was samus the
whole time throw those guns
yeah
he gave us a good then I said it
yesterday and you kind of made me
retract a bit but I'm gonna say it again
I think being that is the best action
game what would you say is the other one
Devil May Cry don't way cry 3 yeah
that's the debate it is a if when they
cry is it Bayonetta or Devil May Cry 3 I
it's been a really long time since I
played three so I would have to replay
it
so I kind of make that yeah so we got
that HD collection coming up soon and
eternal the debate will be over is that
come on switch to think so
being those who ever gonna come up with
PC that we not probably not because of
all the crossover content in it you know
the game only exists because of same
with three yeah guns guns
that's not a gun but we'll take it
[Music]
also the weird like sped up like anime
type animations and the cutscene is
brilliant of them yeah
[Applause]
[Music]
oh there's this line yeah it's a good
one too I didn't remember the we can't
really show it because I'd have to take
it out of the dock and then you guys
won't be able to see it but the game
actually does have touch controls which
was available on the Wii U version yeah
it's sort of like the game's easy mode
and kind of how they put it you also
forgive me I've not played Bayonetta in
a while it's okay we're all gonna
tonight we're all gonna get back into
the Bayonetta flow yeah it's gonna be a
good time a very good time how does the
720p hold up kind of hesitant to move
you know I'm jumping by a switch after
upgrading the 4k games I'm better and
better though it looks I can certainly
understand that especially if you play
it on the PC but I think this actually
looks better than all the other versions
of this game which is a weird thing I
think the big thing for me is that if
you were going from console to this
you're getting it at 60fps which is
pretty good but yeah the game is running
at 720p I'm more of a fan of frame rate
over resolution later this looks good
enough resolution wise to me even though
it is some 720 but like obviously being
at a1 I would say like yeah you know
maybe the PC version but really you're
getting this more for like two and then
you're just kind of getting one yeah
it's it's included as a as a packet and
and two you can only get here so that's
kind of the big thing for me yeah well
even with the stream - we're just
showing one to be like hey guys look one
yeah well so we're showing one a little
bit and then we're gonna we're gonna go
on to rig it to real hard that's me good
time the big thing people really care
about
yeah what 1080p yeah that's understand
yeah yeah
and that is true it is improved over the
the Wii U at it version so I wouldn't go
so far as to say definitive but it's
it's a real good way to do it best way
to play - second best way to play
probably the yep I've actually heard
maybe the best one console is backwards
compatibility for Xbox for Xbox with an
Xbox one X getting really solid 60 so I
I'll never go back and play it on the
360 because I presented it like I got
all the achievements and everything and
I'm like cool I did that and I kind of
want to play it in a place where I don't
have everything unlocked all that but
yeah so excited to play these games
again what I like thinking about all the
movies I could do and I'm like I don't
have any of these unlocked original name
wants to know what our opinions are in
Bayonetta 3 any excitement
oh hell yeah mucho excitement might do
all the excitement so much excitement
waiting for the switch price to go down
that's understandable try to get like a
good deal on it or something I can get
that hope in it is 1080 I'd rather be 60
than 1080 but I imagine it I'm curious
how it will actually look in perform
because there I know they're gonna be
building it specifically for the about
what's going to mess em up all right
because they're gonna be building it for
the switch this is what I wanted to do
wants to know is this a true story a
hundred percent this actually happened
about seven years ago the war between
which is it's eternal yeah it never
stops
Bayonetta four is gonna be a thing I
hope so
let's wait for three first it's true
we're getting we're getting the card
ahead of the horse here so this this
move is too good my favorite move they
have to unlock though is the one where
you hold down the trigger and you spin
pins and then she poses for the cameras
gonna say my favorite one is oh this is
so good and my friend would hate that
move because he found it really annoying
and so I would just do it all the time
oh nice yeah it's that's definitely it
has like almost no practicality like in
actually fighting but it's so rad
also this fight could go on forever I
just want to hear the music the whole
time
I also get to hear that really cool
cover of Moon River and - again yeah
[Music]
pick up a switch for Christmas really
didn't like Mario gonna pick up and out
of three payday Dark Souls most looking
forward to
yo those are some great choices I'm
actually really curious about payday
because I played a lot on the PC oh
there's the the shots they sound
different
I'm curious how well it holds up on the
switch and I really like the idea of
like well Dark Souls on the switch for
sure but how payday is gonna work all
paid it's all good I'm all ready to make
a little money
Joe Pesci it's against regulations your
Pokemon on the switch would be very good
you know what else would be good I mean
our guessing we know we're getting
Pokemon yeah oh not my car oh that base
[Music]
everyone steps away
I forgot that they did these like still
yeah cutscenes as well what's it called
gaku zero also does that where it will
have like oh you motion ones and then
the snow ones is that just a Japanese I
think it might have been a budget thing
for this game
I imagine maybe the same to zero right
got over 3,000 hours on piece you really
like it that infamy 10 hasn't gone you
know what you're set for all a whole new
adventure on the switch then 3000 hours
is very impressive for payday people can
get real real into any payday there's a
lot there to to dig into also it is the
connector for a lot of my video games
are connected theory also in that it
basically proves John wick and iCarly
are part of the same cinematic universe
perfect which is voice wondered while
watching John wick is man where is Carly
and Sam and Freddie what are they doing
but yeah dude originally I would also
cry if there's an animal crossing on
switch and axed
it's not bad at all you don't even have
your real gums yet know where the
Scarborough Fair that's not good mad
farmer Productions is saying they
couldn't get their download codes for
bayonetta 1 to work and two copies they
got oh that's the problem that's a real
big problem I take those back and be
like ayo give me real codes please at
least you can play too but yeah that's
real dumb yeah like that would actually
I'd return that do you know if you get
the payday for DLC with it no clue be
silly if they left it out though sonic
who is who is Eggman dr. Robotnik I mean
okay yes I know that's the reference cuz
this game has just a [ __ ] ton of second
the Halos let's be honest they're
actually just rings oh yeah like is
they're not messing I'm not pulling that
one over
me I forgot like me and Peter probably
they make looking at wood kid
oh it's kidding yeah the there's the the
whole whole part where you're riding on
the rocket is just after burner after
burner it actually plays like I'm using
everything are you sure it was a long
time ago yeah it's definitely a Sega
thing um he'd made some Capcom jokes as
well oh yeah by themself or McAfee
there's the music right there which is
talking about references smacked us
right in the face yep I hope think I
actually noticed that before
okay so extra cat says according to
Reddit if a person with an invalid code
got his game from Amazon Amazon be
issuing a new code later oh dang so this
is a widespread thing we've already got
a plan for I'm really nervous if my code
oh this game is a Bayonetta on the
switch nah man whoops she's she I can't
die she's good
time for exposition ah yes my good
friend exposition is here he does it in
the first one - that's a pretty good
time is there way to make her mass go
down I feel like there has to be forget
about it I guess I'm supposed to be
maybe it's just power armor now yeah we
can't see it it's there trust us
Oh press down on the sound on the d-pad
it's down maybe you have to do it in the
game that's er oh yeah hold it there it
is but you did it Oh
Billabong you're my favorite person I
knew it was there but I didn't remember
and you can do it in cutscenes this is
great is the best thing ever I did not
know that I remember it being a thing
but I was like doing this
that's the only the top-quality things
you can do in these ones this is good
I'm easily amused by this dude same
I'm really glad that I mentioned that
I'm really glad that somewhere back in
that into like the back of my mind I'd
and I'm also glad that we were doing all
your streams so someone could tell me
how to doing Billabong you're that
you're the hero the honorary hero of the
GameSpot stream for today
[Music]
what's the line from the metroid game
remember me and then like the visor
swoop flip switches up the team ninja
Metroid game I remember anything from
that guy oh there's a guy who's like
remember me and then his visor flips up
and you see his face
oh yeah yeah it was a weird like
sideways deep cut but it was a deep cut
I feel so this is the best thing you're
in which time yeah well like what if you
went deeper into gulps time I don't
think you can cuz they're already gonna
in slow motion gotta keep working the
best regards thank you again
Billabong hope your your you're getting
your copy and you're gonna have a good
time enjoy your work yeah yeah well I
gotta film I'm here there you go
so the best sign of a person who hasn't
played beignet in a long time is they do
the torture attack and they forget they
have to spam a button yeah because if
you've been playing Bayonetta you're on
top of that oh yeah you're just
immediately spamming the buddies yeah
yeah apparently hearing from from Tony
on YouTube Bayonetta 2 is the number one
bestseller on Amazon in North America
right now hell yeah
so here we are
Bayonetta is finally getting all that
notice they deserve thanks to Nintendo's
awesome new console I'm not new it's
like a year old now oh that's been a
fast year yeah Wow holy cow
oh and apparently we're talking about
Bayonetta for because Kamiya is already
talking about it presumably on Twitter
Bob okay geez yeah real excited so
that's another thing I want to talk
about apparently a lot of people's
orders are getting delayed until I
connect streak or later in the weekend
yeah - not come until Tuesday I'm
playing the Peters copy I'm the only
person to do this I've you go now cuz
there's too much going on you keep
talking I'm just gonna try and flip this
visor right oh I think I'm the only
person I've talked to in the office that
is getting it today that didn't have to
like request it but it's you it's me
how'd the truck get there yeah
ooh yes just grab the whole car
how much more one do you think we're
gonna we're gonna play through uh too
much more wanted to pretty quick because
that's kind the one people care about
yeah yeah ah the gates of hell my old
stomping grounds they haven't changed
much hold on my visor spell fell down
again and either malfunctioning what up
G status how's it going
even harder with Purgatorio in the
middle fight long enough in there and
you're really lose sight dang this bar
really feels like it's just a callback
to yes yeah yeah the thing that's
missing is I was gonna say someone
kicked up but there's no pizza there was
apparently he was talking about being at
a four on Twitter already I can see
myself in your glasses I was wearing my
normal outfit it's the best music to
upgrade to finding all the weapons like
you get the the LPS and then he goes
down and like monster hunts a demon and
turns them into the weapon yeah that's
really rad like there's a story behind
each one cuz they're all four of them
yeah there they are
ah yes time to do the montage where we
put our guns on and also mix a fine
drink it's just everything so over the
top but in like a believable way it's
really hard to have like hanging in
there thanks for the shoutout
amen I'm glad you're same high class
yeah alright you want more - no actually
I think this might be a good time today
we're gonna we're gonna stop this here
really I just kind of wanted to watch
the intro to one because I loved it it's
such a good intro it sets the tone very
well so today we're actually gonna skip
a little bit of the intro okay alright
um just get to the gameplay I like it
does that mean we're skipping over Moon
River at all I do want to see me oh okay
if you just want to go from the
beginning we can do that - I'm okay with
that
I mean get a good feel of all right into
the world of the switch you know if it's
fair it's fair also it's an excuse to
listen someone favourite cover from both
of the games I like I'd like it more
than than the one in one which I feel
weird about but you know things blew now
I really like the different color
aesthetic - I like being a tattoo
Bayonetta much more than being a tat one
never that was like a controversy yeah
right who were upset that bayonet had
changed her look I can't believe she has
different hair I can't believe a person
would want to change their appearance
what even is this awesome first half off
thank you Nintendo
so we're talking about on a monster
hunter show earlier how this is a great
holiday game yes we've got all these
cool holiday things everywhere
[Music]
it's cool-looking tree happy families ah
there he is
the Hideki Kamiya bear my favorite my
favorite of the bears that's what he
wants to buy for his kid that's what
they want that's a great outfit
yeah also is this isn't pre-render this
is pre-render no this isn't pre-rendered
none of this stuff is pre-rendered
because they have if you had the outfits
it does the outfits yeah I do not have
the outfit in this one yeah they have
them all all the outfits are in both
games nice does not
she treats him like [ __ ] yeah I mean he
kind of deserves it but also come on
she's like [ __ ]
he's trying his best he's trying to buy
toys for his kids hey man this gives her
expensive it's true I was still going on
about the dressing up like a nun had
beaten up all those angels you still
still just you know give an exposition
oh and then you look like [ __ ] backs
up to forget about it look at that girl
and so you're a mess you're a
metaphorical trying to you like she's
not even there anymore
well he's oh she's back
[Laughter]
I probably have a few more choice words
if that happened to me really just one
long drawn-out drew presence on you oh
her bike is called the angel Slayer I
didn't know that I notice it before then
we got a second one we should just watch
all the cutscenes yeah yeah just open up
a youtube channel and just Google all
Bayonetta two kids
yes you do like a Mystery Science
Theater commentary over it you'd
probably fit in another one there
was another thing that happened a lot
when Bayonetta 2 came out was people
would like Photoshop Hideo Kojima's face
under her because she's the same lashes
and stuff yeah oh that's pretty good
it was real good ah yeah cuz you can see
her wings in her shadow yeah no one
notices that like in the like humans
it's one of these games were like humans
are just completely oblivious or they're
also just like yo that woman's like 9
feet tall why is she like why is she 70%
legs what is up with this how she lost
her hat named after that game studio
we'll talk later I'll see you back home
don't forget to pick up the things for
the party
okay you gonna actually have the party
at the end of the game remember like
there comes back at the end that's of
course yeah just why not oh my god I'm
just I'm so stoked for the kick the kick
is the kick is the moment that I live
for in this game
a toy jet
this guy is not even it's just yes sir
quite god I can't wait till I get home
that poor dude everyone just miss treats
everyone like how even though it's still
flying at him he's like I still need my
present I can't leave yes do it yeah
it's so good
what if you could actually unlock that
outfit maybe I I don't think you can but
that even I don't think I'd of is hard
onto as I didn't one so I don't know if
I did and I'm actually excited to dive
the Heart Institute Oh same there like a
lot of the reason I did in this just cuz
like I was like the we you
cuz you gotta do this again mm-hmm it's
very important a lot of the plot and
story beats of this game is just
everything that happened in the first
one yeah like how can we one-up that
yeah yeah uh I love this cover so much
[Music]
this is a little over-the-top though
also I love the fact that this is like a
Nintendo like Nintendo was like yes do
all of this on our console please
Nintendo's it's weird like I remember
when they when they did like they show
them like the concept for like the
bayonet outfit where it's like Oh like
we had a idea for like a sexy peach
costume yeah yeah and it said it won't
prevent it was like yeah man yes put it
in make it sexier what is this game play
this isn't game play exactly but it this
is kind of how gameplay works
here we go beat him up John Luke beat
him up oh this looks good yeah this
looks real good
there's like there's there's something
that's just a little more clean about it
than what I remember yeah I can't put my
finger on like it's not like better
textures per se it's not there's just
something that's cleaner I don't know
exactly what to do oh this is good - do
you do you get your your actual guns
earlier because I think you do I think
right now yeah there we go
Santa rode on she drives the car like up
on the wall at one point I think we're
getting there
did it again yeah ramps off the car and
drives on the side of the building uh
this is the Crazy Taxi reboot I always
wanted there we go yeah
[Music]
it may not be coming over the the stream
as well but it it definitely looks
better than the Wii U version it runs
better and it runs better than the Wii
runs better it's gotta care about the
toys beautiful it's just one big
callback let's say watching it
back-to-back is giving me much more
appreciation for it right on the battle
theme yep
turn the game up I got you
a little bit of that that's sweet
Bayonetta music music tracks Oh
[Music]
yeah
yeah which do you like better this
battle theme or the one in one I think I
like this one more there's more vocals
in it
I do like ones covered fly me to the
moon yeah like what find me the moon's
classic a plus but man this is so good
these games are just fun yeah now koobs
back
welcome back to time for this for the
the snake fight the sky snake fight
you know I feel like saying that
Nintendo scamming people with these
roommates is kind of silly because like
I don't need to buy this I mean if
you're a big Bayonetta fan you've
already bought it and there's also a
really high possibility you're already
sitting here playing I mean in the case
of plague Richard the he loves vena to
wine he never played Bayonetta 2 though
because he never owned a Wii U so one of
the reasons he ended up buying a switch
was because Bayonetta just for Bayonetta
I don't just exclusively but that was
like a big thing of like oh time to
finally get it like yeah that's really
read I'm excited that more people are
gonna get a cast it really is just like
wait for people to get it and I think it
would be a bit more alarming if Nintendo
was also not making new games this way
they totally are
ai ai don't line the switch having all
these like reports for really good games
that you know where people come out
oh [ __ ] would it be an edit to come out
over a while ago 13:14 yeah yeah what
was it was a few years ago scamming the
three people who bought oh we you look
there were at least five I bought one
zero at least so no John Luke had one I
had one that's two why isn't Bayonetta 2
on PC of blitz it's because there's a
lot of Nintendo content in it and also
it Nintendo help fund it yeah it exists
basically solely because Nintendo
stepped in and were like hey this is a
thing that needs to happen put it on our
console will basically give you the
money to make it make it I mean in a
Nintendo I think did it because they
needed stuff for that we use so in a lot
of ways you could kind of contribute the
declining so here's the thing I think a
lot of people were like all this game
would have come out to other systems if
it wasn't for nintendo that's not true
the game would have never existed
yeah so in a weird way you could say
that like the failing health of the Wii
U is the only reason Bayonetta 2 exists
yeah well so that's that's not it's not
a good argument either I bought this
with my money
just like I bought the first game and
the second game originally and then I
bought the first game again on Steam I
just like Bayonetta I love that and the
fact that I can now portably take both
Bayonetta games wherever I want to go
will read me and he worked really well
on the dock - yeah after this I'm not
gonna I'm not gonna give you that one
after this I'm gonna pull out the joint
cause we're gonna give it a joy Kongo
will give enjoy Kongo after at this
whole intro
that's another good thing to John brings
up a good point I'm really surprised at
how many games are just are on the
switch like there's a lot I wholly
expected it to not be like a thing that
I'd go back to a lot and a thing that
I'd kind of prefer for a lot of games
but it's a real good system and it has
tons of things to play on somebody call
us a journalist over there yeah that's
fine well so that's another thing
neither of us are journalists now
surprised even though I I studied
English and journalism in college I did
take a non estroux I'm a liar first day
and I was like 10 I take a journalism
class in college you don't even do that
so now definitely not a journalist
zero journalistic credibility I just
have zero credibility oh yeah I'm still
trying to figure out why why I'm feeling
like this this just looks better I think
part of it really is the 60 frames so it
wasn't 60 before now it was kind of like
like a 45 50 okay wasn't locked one of
those reverie too excited for this boob
same
you guys want to have like a really cool
band anything out oh yeah I think a lot
of people are excited for it yeah I
think a lot of did say it was
top-selling on the on Amazon Amazon
right in North America yeah so obviously
people are stoked about Bayonetta yeah
I'm gonna secure and trying to make here
you can hear yeah I'm good okay good
so the sound kind of did a weird thing
but yeah yeah that's just on our ends
you guys should be fun yeah Oh eat them
up yeah I don't really want to talk
about like we yeah stuff like that in
the time or yeah we've said our piece so
let's talk about cool this is it's too
and then they pulled the the old
switcheroo on this yeah made them not
good because they broke out
your hair demon escaped so I I like I
think I like Bayonetta 2 more than being
at a 1 overall but the one thing that
I'm really upset about with Bayonetta 2
is it doesn't doesn't have like they're
really cool like boss fight at the end
like one did her for one or two now it
was like the end of one you throw like a
god into the sun' oh yeah once is pretty
over-the-top and I was really kind of
hoping for something like that into but
not the case unfortunately but still
salt really good time though
[Music]
this aerial fighting was also an odd
thing but that's kind of into oh yeah
yeah I'm surprised by how how it
actually kind of worked because usually
that kind of thing doesn't doesn't flow
she kind of autumn moves to the guy yeah
bingo
so it's basically DMC right so it's it's
another like character action game in
the vein of Delta like the bane of devil
my Christ so if if you like the kind of
game like Devil May Cry or like yeah
it's by the same people who made the
first three Devil May Cry 's no in that
sense it is like a spiritual successor
to devil may cry like for sure yeah like
there are more definitely Christ after
though after one two three yes is the
original people who made what is
Bayonetta about and should you have
played one before too or are they
separate in their story um I don't think
usually I can get away without playing
playing to without it but it definitely
actually does reference it is actually
pretty heavily tied to yeah it'll help
your experience but you can totally play
them separate yeah so I'd recommend
playing one to two shoot they visit if
it's your first time okay this first
first boss fight back in the saddle
getting that which time
yeah
also how I want to like I've always kind
of wanted like a peek into like the
creative process behind like who's like
I'm gonna make a main character who is a
witch and her gimmick is she hits things
with her hair maybe like a like a like a
like a hair whip kind of thing no like
her whole body is covered like it turns
into a demon and it turns into a demon
that punches things like giant arms and
someone has to be like them to draw this
out for me because I'm not entirely sure
what you're what you're throwing at some
concept like I I like where you're going
but I don't know if I follow and it
worked out really well
oh I agree Kevin these games are great
and also getting both of them for 60
bucks --is pretty good pretty good yeah
[Music]
Fuchs actually brings up a really good
point it is it's like double main cry
but a little bit more campy which I mean
Democrat three it's pretty it's pretty
campy too
he's got a like a slice of pizza they
definitely up that I like it though I
like the camp I'm man what do you think
that that rumored dump my car for is
gonna be like or five sorry not for I
apologized for yeah I don't know I'm
curious if they'll they'll go with like
a new thing or kind of continue on from
where the actual floor went or take more
of a DMC approach I'm excited to play it
either way
we're back at the gates of Hell make me
another drink
look the last DMC where the guy put his
pants on while flying through the
trailer that's that good stuff I like I
like DMC
same
I'm really happy they didn't change the
music here - excuse me
I like this um like clock game instead
of the yeah it makes it easier to see
what's happening which is definitely
better and so no stop no hard bass you
that's that'd be interesting like a
bayonetta DMC crossover kind of
situation happening I don't know how
they would I don't know it's Capcom and
Platinum on good terms
yeah oh no I they're so I really don't
know also how would that dynamic play
out because like well I mean they both
kind of do the same thing right except
she doesn't well she hunts demons in
this one yeah this one like she's
hunting the demons down yeah instead of
the instead of the angels we have 20
gigabytes left on my switch what's the
file size for both games does anyone
know dude did you happen to see that at
all so I know that the part fur too
won't take up any space which one takes
up it probably can't it's probably not a
lot because it was a like a 360 ps3 game
I don't know how much more space it
might take a fixed rakat says 14 814 and
I think that would make sense eight
point four gigs houses Kelvin
so is her dog actually Santa is that
what they're trying to imply with all
this Oh baby that that man's really
Santa Claus because I'm okay with that
that would be a good good development
first character I feel tell me about it
all the coop was another really good
thing to I think get a chance to do a
lot of it with someone else
I did a lot of its solo I forgot
Yosuke adult Yosuke oh no I won't be
able to see him as anything else other
than that now
should I override Peters record did you
did you do better better than him I
guess I thinks maybe yeah you did he got
a bronze don't tell him no one tell him
all right look like models from Saints
Row I don't know if I see it do you have
the this pin move yeah does he have the
oh no oh the one where you hold down the
trigger let's we'll find out ah here he
is these bullet holes in the ground can
only mean one thing let me put on my
spectacles
I think excellently skipped a couple
scripted chapter backs and wasn't paying
attention
yeah it's possible oh well that's fine
let's go we're just jumping in like
yikes
at L&T man a dumb schemes real silly
adult yes gay oh that's the other good
thing the if you're looking to get some
memory expansion going on for your
switch it takes basically any any minor
SD card so you get them for super cheap
doing what is this idiot give it a
history lesson to himself you lost your
head why is he got you see his pants
they're like those like western like
they got the little he's got a very
western theme going and frillies yeah do
you like my glasses he's got like cowboy
boots yeah the time
hey like there's a Triforce perfect I
didn't even see that before there's so
much stuff in either city even see it
again
he's like a journalist isn't he right
yeah we ah yes exposition let's get back
into the action yeah so we just get into
this gameplay yep
look at that Triforce perfect oh yeah
hey dang
it's all over the place cats yeah what
up cat hey cats got a small head
yeah but he's one of those a challenge
area are we'll find out here in a second
yeah it is a challenge area I'm read
these being tough like a little later
ones yeah they're like you have to kill
like 20 things without touching the
grounds oh oh oh I think there's a oh
you can only use the one right okay
there we go
I'm replaying this whole weekend this is
bad
I wasn't prepared for this I had plans
BAM did it
holy Sh love the the achievements just
in game oh cool that's nice
oh boy in the rain game before because
the Wii U but gave the way you work that
way I'm trying remember I think they had
like in-game things I wonder if they
have them in one curious oh yeah it has
amiibo support oh what's that you I
don't know about that I have the
Bayonetta 2 amiibo same I'm very curious
find out you mean a Bayonetta 1 amiibo
as well tonight yeah yeah is this gonna
be on Xbox one unfortunately not new but
if you're looking for a good action game
they're releasing the Devil May Cry HD
collection and it's smart yeah and two
of those are good yes this is a I'll get
you two good games I'm at a mathematical
fact but how many games are in it three
what yeah I mean you can play two if you
want to yeah one is one is a good is
still a good game but it also isn't like
quite the devil may cry you think of
like we think Devil May Cry jeez I'm
what happened oh my goodness oh they're
all they're all bloody and angry that's
probably why so have to beat up the guy
who's his buffalo first I found thanks
this buffer yeah
you assumed dante vs. bayonetta on
youtube I haven't yet but that sounds
like a thing I should check out I bet
that screw tak video Oh like the death
battle thing yeah I think they still do
those I think you do too
I haven't checked one out in a while it
feels like those like a decade ago oh
there we go yeah confirmed it is alright
cool yeah
whoo alright a little kick in the teeth
there it's right you gotta get those
those those checks you know to remind
you how to how to work it no I don't
dang Peter didn't even leave you any
lollipops look they got four weapons
it's a good question does he have like
the the swords oh it's got nothing
Jackie Rooney's no not the whip not the
swords well there's some things you
could use the crafts and crap you're
feeling crafty
[Music]
think I'll just training my WiiU copies
to get this cheap and be nice to have
all three on the same system that's a
pretty good way to do it to anyone I
haven't traded in games in a long time
yeah Sam which I feel like it
I feel like trading in games is a good
thing like you you feed like the game
you coach you do know believe in the
heart of the cards I totally forgot like
he's got the Millennium Eye like that
had to be intentional right what is
maybe being out of one is my favorite
bayonetta maybe I'm reassessing this oh
man
we got for that card too late teleported
away all but this battles real good
Surf's Up
hey go turn yeah yeah got the cool stuff
we do with time manipulation like look
at the way she stands her back that's
not physics it's like she has to stand
that way so she doesn't fall over all
right she's like constantly halfway away
from like striking a jojo pose
what if Bayonetta was just a Jojo Kerr
she would fit right in oh my goodness
my back hurts just watching goop says
same all right she keeps bringing up the
party party yeah you ever see a door
just just want to kick it the wrong
button it's okay it's it's getting back
into it goof also I'm definitely gonna
die nah dude you got this this guy he's
gonna he's gonna swing his stuff real
slow he's got a big old dumb hammer see
it's in the bag
I didn't count on two of them though
yeah ride him ride him right into the
other one yeah and all the like the
random things you can do in combat that
just mixed up like picking up their
weapons
[Music]
like this what would be another stand be
called it's a good question male 1 uh
what control are we using it's a
splatoon pro controller oh yeah I should
try the truck comes out oh you go for it
you use them like separator I have no
choice I didn't bring a thing Oh evil
yu-gi-oh
who would have seen this coming the
Shadow Realm I don't know enough about
you vo to jump in on these jokes all
know about yo-yo is there was a kid in
middle school who challenged me to a
duel with his own cards and I beat him
and then he walked away really sad
dejected and that was the only time I
ever played you yo I haven't I'll tell
you later I can't tell you now okay I
have a funny thing hmm let's see
I might have to seek a change the
controller over doesn't seem I think I
might have to go to the menu well in
that case I might not be alright most
people are really dying you know keep
the flow going uh Rhys on YouTube wants
to know is this game worth 50 bucks if
you haven't played it absolutely
absolutely if you're a big fan of them
and you want to play them on the go yeah
go for it
I'm really excited to play them again
but if there are definitely action games
to not to not be missed
yeah if you like these kinds of games
and you haven't played this then yeah
there's no reason not to play this god
you're right the theme for this one is
very good get more games like this I
hope a DMC will come soon for the ps4
same Robin I more action games the
better its I feel like it's a like game
genre we don't see a lot of and I'd
really like more without a doubt
no gross cowboy well [ __ ] this water one
that had the weird Cuban boss up in this
one I remember that being we yeah
also I I like how like if you've played
enough Bayonetta like in one sitting or
like if you've played enough in it like
over a couple of days did you ever have
the thing where you kind of just got
into like like a a mode where you just
know whenever an attack was coming
anything about it up that's a real weird
feeling and I haven't had a thing like
that I had it when I was playing metal
your rising cuz like you just focus on
one thing for long enough yeah
can you enjoy one without earth can you
enjoy two without buying one so the good
thing about buying two now is it
includes a copy of it if you get it
physically by now separately digitally
put I feel like buying it physically is
a much better option
yeah so I was distracting you can
totally enjoy it without one
yeah but like we said there's no reason
no did you you let her get grabbed but
grabbed by the Ghoulies the wrong thing
oh no well I mean this is a perfect time
to switch up the controller if you want
to try find out because I feel like 310
uh which probably over now they're like
twenty I'm in um oh no I'm here to hang
out is gonna set me back there alright
well then let's not do that well let's
go to AA parody so let's go here the
gates of paradise let's try this chapter
so many cool Boston's in even beyond
just the bosses like you did the generic
enemy design - oh yeah there are so many
different enemies I mean that's I think
the key to a good book character action
game like this is
if the enemies are good yeah you have to
have good I forgot that it's not oh yeah
she's up beats did you have to write
into a flippin yeah a snake fight I'm
honestly really good at asking for
cutscene cuz I think that's funny here
dude hang ten sick as hell whoa
ah Paradiso my favorite local pizza
place
Paradiso pizza get yourself a pie
[Music]
I'll try to remember the setup for this
now water tornado you look out for that
whole building is it a long game it's
it's fairly lengthy and a lot of like a
lot of games in this genre it's it's got
a lot of like replayability oh yeah so
like you'll you'll play through once you
unlock weapons you'll come back through
with those weapons you unlock and get
more weapons uncover more things get
more items go back to on a higher
difficulty one thing I like about this
one more than one is I think it's
gimmick sections I think are more
enjoyable than oh yeah I think ones wear
out their welcome yeah like you were
talking about the afterburner bit which
is good but it wears out its welcome
real quick yeah it's it's maybe the big
down downer for that game
there was an achievement tied to like
doing it without getting hit or
something you thank you no way you did
it I didn't you've got 100 sad I don't I
don't remember exactly if that was the
achievement but I remember doing it a
couple of times it was a thing
[Music]
like this sections cool Sean Nicholson
on YouTube says that's what I like
value and replayability same my dude
Oh Oh Mason says they just they just
joined off off of watching old cam and
set up a soda ah Skyrim mods through
some good times
no amiibo costumes we we haven't done
anything with the amiibo yet yeah but
they are they're in here they're there
for sure I'm pooping right now great
name
it's a very very good name did they have
anything to say or now I I mean these
just said I genders as gamespot I just
like their name though it's IGN
streaming right now I don't know are
they usually when people bring that out
it's because there's streams again if
they are tell me who's on it and you
know I'll send him a thing like a
these big gates
Bayonetta makes underwater levels fun
that's true that's that's the thing you
can actually say I also just like the
design of everything like it's all shiny
and weird and sort of gross
yeah well it's like that it looks like
really majestic but then underneath as
soon as you break through it the angels
will look like super gross ah you hated
Paradiso
but it's Paradiso the city of paradise I
[Music]
mean this way
[Music]
oh they are streaming it who who's on it
oh thank you I'm pooping I I appreciate
it it makes me feel feel good
we're all we're all just hanging out
playing playing video games I'm gonna
keep I keep like putting out breaths
into the microphone and I'm trying not
to after like do it Tay Zonday and like
look away as a good reference uh so this
deep he follows me on Twitter and I
don't know why oh dang when I remember
one day all of a sudden I just got a
notification that was like following on
Twitter and I was like what the terrain
[Laughter]
hi am i late not not too late that
you're you're not gonna be a hangout for
a bit but we're probably gonna go for
about 15 minutes okay probably stop
being a little long sure Luke and I have
been been on a stream thing today for a
very long time yeah and we should
probably get back to doing our actual
work as much as we love hanging out with
you guys and playing games we love ya
hello to you as well audio I'm glad you
could make it even if it is at the end
when I had your Wii U this is one of
your favorite levels see there you go we
got we got people all over the place
saying it's their least favorite it is
their favorite it's it's what you make
of it first time we've seen this it
looks amazing
shadow game if you haven't played
Bayonetta this is get up on this kid in
here play this game true luminous
technically is work but like there's
there's work outside of this work that
it might I mean this was primarily what
my date was gonna be with playing this
game but there are several things I have
to take care of before I go home there
you go so it's a it's a long weekend for
us too so I'm gonna have some stuff
prepared should I go or no no stays it's
all good yeah don't leave don't leave me
you just got here
do I have anything I doubt it
yeah I don't think your your inventories
got macho's Magic's good doesn't have
any of the weapons yet he's impressed
with how great this perform in the EU
I'm really looking forward to seeing how
this works undocked I was watching Peter
play it pretty good like if if it holds
up pretty well like this like that's I
still have moments where I'm playing my
switch and I'm kind of like holy what
like I'm playing like the newest mario
kart game on a hand hug like that kind
of stuff is really cool buying this this
weekend you show me how amazing it is
I'm glad to have helped you find a new
game that you're hopefully going to
enjoy I think you'll have a good time I
like tacos
same to see dog tacos are great all
right the shadow remains cast love is
over that's the one they did the
call-out are you gonna do you do it
again I'm gonna get one more time do it
do it you got this may have to get this
do it John Nicholson do that thing
G status I am we brought it up we
brought it up earlier and I think a game
with pulse Bayonetta and Dante would be
interesting I'm still curious how it
would work I would buy it in an instant
I know that much
man that's got some like high-level
fanfiction stuff I'm way into
Oh
I think God maybe I'll do a smooth promo
real quick while you're fighting this
boss alright if you guys like what you
see make sure you you follow them
subscribe so you don't miss a single
show we do we're live anytime we can be
every everyday at like 11 o'clock
sometimes we'll do special ones or we we
come in later in the day and we'll show
you like Bayonetta because it just came
out but count on eleven so if you
followed subscribed you can always get
notified whenever it happens and we
won't miss you and we want and want you
to come and hang out with us anyone
playing us on the train home lumen you
know I would if I got sent to the office
well plate when I get home though
she's just constantly trash-talking it's
so good it's so close
also I like the kind of one Epps devil
may cry with taunts and that she has
like depending on how long you hold the
talk button and she does like three
different taunts right which is very
good yeah
I'm kind of getting like like I'm
getting caught up and just watching you
like like this yeah I'm like really
trying to focus some time saying much I
need to I need to not focus because
you're focusing I need to I need to I
need to commentate focus here see it
over wait your boy is tired and they're
excited for the weekend there we go whoa
so this whole stream we haven't had like
I think like a a boss fight thing yet
goodness
do it did aah oh my gosh I didn't even
think about what are they gonna do to if
the games are constantly trying to
one-up each other what are they gonna do
in 3 2 1 up to right now how crazy will
it get how over-the-top will it go never
be allowed to reach the mountain
[Music]
goodbye
those wings look really cool though too
I think she actually curses more in this
one too how's it going mr. dent love
this game same taking a break from
playing Bayonetta because of your thumb
is blistered you're having a good time
though I feel that yeah right getting
this right now do it on writable
rewritable unreadable Wow
yeah that's a good spot on it yeah I'm
fun feeling how's it go away so with me
getting a perfect platinum on Bayonetta
yeah oh this quest crazy it's a wild
right yeah yeah anything you want to
want to say this game still real good if
you've never played Bayonetta
and you don't know switch and you like
these kinds of games I got no excuse not
to play this game pick it up by the game
play the game be the best in the world
best witch have a great weekend everyone
bye miss you
[Music]
[Music]